سباق مع الزمن لاستغلال الساعات المقبله
على امل العثور على ناجينا تحت الانقاض في
المناطق المتضرره بالزلزال في سوريا
وتركيا الا انه مع مرور الوقت تتضائل
الفرص للعثور على احياء فيما تزداد اعداد
الجزر التي يتم اخراجها من تحت الركامى
وفي جديد المساعدات الدوليه اعلن البنك
الدولي انه بصدد تقديم مساعدات الى تركيا
بقيمه مليار و780 مليون دولار لتمويل
اعمال الاغاثه والتعافي فيما لم يعلن
لغايه الان عن اي مساعدات من البنك الدولي
الى سوريا بشكل مباشر مشاهدينا تغطيه
العربيه مستمره لكارثه الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا
الحمد لله الحمد لله
نحن عم نحفره ونطلع ما طلعنا منه
[موسيقى]
مسعود هانزر رجل تركي تجاوز الخمسين من
عمره كغيره من الملايين ترك فيه الزلزال
ندبه لن تختفي
[موسيقى]
جلس هانسر قرب مبنى متهدم في قهرمان مرعش
ممسكا بيد ممتده من بين الالقاب يدي طفلته
التي ماتت عن 15 سنه
يرفض ان يتركها وسط الدمار يقول ادم التان
مصور وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه الذي وثق
الماسه ان الابا المكلوم همس له قائلا
التقط صوره لطفلتي ثم بقي ساكنا لساعات
يحدق في العدم
يتشبث بيدي فقيدته غير مبال بالبرد والمطر
ويضيف المصور هذا الالم لا يطاق
[موسيقى]
بابا
لا تخاف
طلع لي
لا تخوف تمام
اخير وداع من تحت الانقاض خيبه تلو الاخرى
ركام لا يلفظ الا الجسد والقليل من الحياه
صباح اخر والكارثه تتوسع وتضيق فيها فرص
النجاه
يتفقد هذا الرجل الحطام محاوله متعثره
للبحث عن عائلته ابتلعت الانقاض ما لا يقل
عن 17 من افراد اسرته حتى الان لم تسعفه
ذاكرته حتى بعد ان جفت الدموع قال لك
راحوا اخوي
ونسوان اثنين معه
كارثه مدويه بالسنطيه تحايل عليها
المنقذون على امل سماع من يطلب النجاه
صوت من بطن الارض هذا المراد لا غير
تسير عمليات الانقاذ بلا توقف وبحسب خبراء
الفتره الذهبيه لانقاذ الارواح في مثل هذه
الكوارث شارفت على الانتهاء ونقص الغذاء
وطقس البارد عاملان توفرهما يزيد المشهد
مراره
الاطفال الاوفر حظا في النجاه رغم وفاه
الالاف منهم لكن ما ينتظرهم مقلق وفق
اليونيسف غالبيه الاطفال ينجون دون
عائلاتهم ما يعمق من ازمه الطفوله
المفقوده في سوريا طوال السنين الماضيه
ضحايا كارثه الزلزال يقترب عددهم من
العشرين الف قتيلا في سوريا وتركيا راحوا
جميعهم في حادثه تزلزلت فيها الارض ودكت
من عليها
غذاء السالم العربيه
اذا وصل عدد القتلى في تركيا وسوريا الى
22 الفا حسب المرصد السوري بسوريا ان هناك
اربعه الاف قتيل
وبالنسبه للمجموعه العامه للقتل بين سوريا
وتركيا وصل الى 22 الفا من مدينه اعزاز
قرب حلب ينضم الي عاطف نعنوع مدير فريق
ملهم التطوعي عاطف اهلا بك معنى كيف يمكن
ان تصف لنا الاوضاع في اليوم الخامس يعني
بدانا في هذا اليوم الخامس ساعات قليله
تفصلنا عن اليوم الخامس
مساء الخير لكل الساده المشاهدين الرحمه
لشهداء الزلزال والشفاء العاجل للجرحى
للاسف كلمه يعني اليوم الاول كان تاثير
لسه تحت تاثير الصدمه ما عم نشوف
الاحصائيات اللي عم تتزايد بهالطريقه
باليوم الخامس الارقام الضحايا بتزيد
ارقام الجرحى بيزيد والقصص تطفو لحتى
نسمعه لحتى نشوفها بنكتشف قديش يعني الوضع
كل ما نعبزداد سوء من لما من لما حصل
الزلزال لحد اللحظه بفكر انه اذا بدنا
نلخص اللي صار بكم جمله بنقول انه بيوم من
الايام
الساعه 4:30 الفجر
صار زلزال بمنطقه منكوبه اصلا الى 12 سنه
تعرض للقصف اثناء عاصفه ثلجيه الساعه 4:30
الفجر كان كل الناس تحت اسقف تابع عاطف
اليوم الوضع كيف كيف يمكن ان تصفه لنا
اليوم للاسف الوضع يعني
كان اخر يعتقل الدفاع المدني او الاعمال
اللي عم بيشتغلوا انه اليوم اخر يوم متل
ما انحكى بالتقريب الفتره الذهبيه شارفت
على الانتهاء
فصار الشغل بالمعدات بشكل اسرع لما نشوف
لما نشوف الفيديوهات الظاهره على الشاشه
ان المعدات تشتغل اكثر من البشر هذا بيعني
انه الامل شبه فقط لانه ما بقى في حذر مثل
البدايه بانه يكون الشغل يدوي لانه ما في
اصوات ما في اي اثر لاي اشخاص وبالتالي
الدفاع المدني والمتطوعين مضطرين على انه
يشيل الركام يعجلوا من من يعني يزيدوا
سرعه العمل لعل لعل وعسى انه يظهر معهن
شيء هنا نوعيه وهنا المستعجلين لانه ما
بقى في وقت ابدا لاخراج الضحايا او او
الاشخاص تحت الانقاذ احياء بعد هاي الفتره
الزمنيه يعني تضائلت تضائلت الامل كثيرا
وليس هناك من مؤشرات على اي ناجين
تحت انقاض هذه الابنيه المدمره ومع هيك
اليوم الحمد لله رب العالمين في عدد من
يعني من الاشخاص له احيانا تحت الانقاض
الحمد لله رب العالمين ولكن باي منطقه
بناطق مثل بريف ادلب ومنطقه
حلب اما بالنسبه للعدد الضحايا اللي عم
يطلعوا طبعا عددهم اكبر اذا بدنا نحكي شوي
عن الوضع
الانساني فكمان مع باليوم الرابع والخامس
بلشت تظهر اثار زلزال انسانيا لانه الناس
اللي كانت اصلا بدها تنزح او عم تنزح ما
كان في موجود النزوح الكبير لانه كانت
الناس ناطره اخراج اقربائهم من تحت الارض
اليوم بعد ما الامل او طلعوهم ودفنوهم
بلشوا ينتشروا بالمدن المحيطه فمنلاقي
كثير
لكل مكان لكل مكان عدد عدد يعني نحن عم
نحكي عن المدن مثل مدينه جنديرس مثلا هي
كلها او نصها على الارض ونصها غير قابل
للسكن المباني الدرج كبير فنحكي عن مدينه
واحده في حوالي 20 الف
شخص شخص
ولكن بعد النزوح الى الضعف العدد اربعه
خمس مرات فبالت عن مناطق سكنيه مختصه
بالسكان كلها بدون استثناء الشمال السوريه
كان يمكن يعددوا
قد النص لما قبل 2011 بعد عمليات النزوح
حاليا كل كل مدينه فيها اربع اضعاف حتى
عمليات البناء احنا بنشوف قسمين من
المباني المهدومه طبعا القسم الاكبر من
المهتومه هو ما تم بناؤه بهذه الفتره بسبب
غياب وجود الدوله لانه في عمار عمليات
اعمار
مستمره ومتسارعه وغير النظاميه بزيد
المخالفات بتزيد من كميه الدمار لما يحصل
من مراكز ايواء لهؤلاء الناس ان فقط
ينتقلون مثلا لعند اقاربهم في مناطق اخرى
طبعا الناس بالبدايه بتروح عند عند
اقاربهم على المخيمات وخاصه هلا مثل يعني
لما نحكي عن الخيام
للمصادف انا لابس بلوزه مكتوب عليها حتى
اخر خيمه هو مشروعنا عم نشتغل عليه بسوريا
بالسنه الاخيره لحتى يكون في حل مستدام
تطلع الناس من الخيام هذا الخيمه هي الحلم
بالنسبه للناس ما في خيام بالسوق ابدا حتى
لو شراء جمعيات ما عندها خير لانه اصلا ما
كان في حالات نزول في الفتره الماضيه
فالناس عم بتدور على الخيم وين ما كان مع
بلاقوا خيام فبالتالي يروحوا على الجوامع
او على عند اقربائهم هي فتره مؤقته
وبالنهايه اللازمه نحل لانه اصلا اقربائهم
ساكنين بمخيمات الخيمه شو بدات ساعه لما
يجي شخص لما يجي خمس اشخاص ينضافوا فوق
سبع او ثمان اشخاص موجودين بخيمه واحده
وين بدهم يناموا وانا اقل من المساعدات
بدا اتصل الى الشمال السوري ام بعد في
اخبار اليوم عن المساعدات وصلت نقوم متحده
يمكن اربع شاحنات للاسف في يعني تاخر
بوصول المساعدات بالفتره الاولى وال
الاولى لكن احنا بحاجه لمساعدات من نوع
ثاني من اللي تعودنا عليهم لانه نحن
بكارسه انسانيه بحاجه الى يعني مساعدات من
نوع خاص مثل الاليات الثقيله الحديثه او
مثل وسائل الحديثه اللي بيستخدموها هيئات
الكوارث اثناء وقوع الزلازل من من يعني
صواريخ او كمبروسات حديثه للتعامل بحساسيه
مع الاسقف الهابطه واللي هي تحت في ناس او
او يعني في اشخاص تحت الاوقات بيكونوا
بحاجه للخبراء من نوع خاص بالعاده بيكون
عددهم بالعشرات بس بيعملوا فرق كبير بهيك
كوارث ما وصلنا شيء منه للاسف بسبب انه
نحن موجودين بمنطقه يعني
يعني هي اصلا
كيف هو بالنسبه لاعزاز هي ابعد عن عن مركز
الزلزال هي وضع مشبه الى منطقه عنتاب
التركيه بينما بنشوف احنا
مشابهه لموضوع انطاكيا يعني لذلك سالتك
عاطف هل مثلا الناس تتوجه الى اعزاز هل
هناك مثلا الان
اصبحت اعداد الناس اكثر في اعزاز بما انها
هي كانت بعيده الى حد ما عن نقطه الزلزال
بالنسبه بالنسبه للناس توجهوا بحسب وجود
اقاربون فنحن بنشوف انه التوجه بالنزوح
بريف ادلب لانه المنطقه المتضرره
هي بمنطقه يعني اخر اخر مدينه بريف حلب
باتجاه ادلب وثلاثه او اربع مدن فبالتالي
للمناطق الاقرب لانه الناس حواليهم اقارفه
لم يتوجهوا الى عزاز
لا ما في توجه كبير طبعا في عائلات انا
مبارح لما يعني
شفت عائله فور بما انه عنا مشاريع سكنيه
بعزاز عائلتين تم توجيههم فورا الاعزاز في
بعض العائلات طبعا
على اساس بس ولكن ليس لجوء كثيف لا لا
حالات حالات فرديه بكل المناطق حالات
فرديه اما بالنسبه لمنطقه منطقه جنديرس
فالنزوح منا لا باتجاه ريف ادلب كثيف جدا
يعني مثل المناطق مثل في في قريه كامله
بسنه اسمها بريف ادلب عباره عن 150 بيت
تجمع سكني جديد هبط بشكل كامل ولا بيت
بعيد فبالتالي كان في كتير كبير الاشخاص
اللي اللي عم نحكي 150 بس احنا عم نحكي عن
750 نسمه تقريبا فبالتالي الاشخاص اما
خرجوا يعني
المقابر للاسف او خرجوا للمشاه فيها
فبالتالي الوقت الحالي الناس بالمشافي
المشافي مليانه يعني فالناس نقاط طبيه
مليانه هل لديها قدره هذه المشاكل هذا
العدد من الناس هل هناك من كادر طبي هل
هناك من مواد طبيه
لانه اساسا هذه المنطقه منكوبه قبل
الزلزال
بالتاكيد الفكره وين اول يوم بعد الزلزال
حوالي بعد ست ساعات وجهت لمشفى عفرين مشفى
عفرين كان غير قادر على استيعاب اي حاله
اضافيه احنا بنحكي عن اول ست ساعات بعد
الزلزال فما بالكم لحد اللحظه او ثاني يوم
اللي بيكون تم في اخراج الناس من تحت
الانقاذ كانت الناس او كانت الجرحى
موجودين
بممرات المشفى العينين طبعا طلبوا مني
للمشفى انه نجيب اغطيه للناس لان الناس
الممرات ما فتت فئه عاصفه ثلجيه قائمه
طلبوا مننا اول شيء نجيب بطانيات للناس
فتخيلوا المظهر المنظر هذا باول ست ساعات
المشافي والكوادر الطبيه وكان بمشفى عفرين
لانه ذكرنا الحادثه بعد ست ساعات طلب مني
الممرض لو انه نامن دكتور عصبيه دكتور
عاصميه نحن بنعرف انه حالات العصبيه هي
اكثر حالات بعد الزلازل ما كان في ولا
دكتور اخصائي بمشفل عفرين الوطني يعني هو
يعد اكبر مشروع المنطقه وعرفيني مدينه
مركزيه ما كان فيها طبيب عصبيه ولا الطبيب
عظميه
في نقيس هذا الشيء على كل
المشافي التانيه للاسف على جروب التنسيق
حاليا بنشوف كل شوي انه هلا هلا وصلنا خبر
انه مشفى مركز دم الاتاري بحاجه الى يمكن
الف وحده دم لانه في عندهم نقص بالدم
بنشوف انه الادويه في في حاجه كتير
الادويه في حاجه
للمازوت الديزل الاليات تبع الدفاع المدني
كل يوم بحاجه الى 50 الف ديزل يمكن متوقع
هيك كان الرقم امبارح اول خمس ايام يعني
خمسين الف دولار يعني فبالتالي
انه المساعداتها ما وصلت فمن من من
فعاليات الدفاع المدني او من من مخزون
الدفاع المدني اللي كان للامانه
يعني كالعاده الشباب ما قصروا ابدا 24
ساعه بيشتغلوا
بالحفر بالاضافه الى متطوعين من من الفئات
المدنيه
الخيريه اللي عم تساعد بدعم الدفاع المدني
سواء بشراء بعض المعدات الخفيفه والاليات
المتوسطه والمعدات الحفر تسديدا بالوقود
يعملوا يعني يعني شيء يقدروا انه يخففوا
من اثار الكارثه لانه احنا يعني دائما
بنقول انه لو كان في معدات احدث لو كان في
تدخل سريع من قبل اشخاص خبراء كان الوضع
راح يكون افضل من هيك ولكن الحمد لله على
كل حال شكرا لك عاطف نعنوع كنت معي مدينه
عزاز قرب حلب مدير فريق ملهم التطوعي
الان سانتقل الى خالد ابو المجد الصحفي
على الحدود السوريه التركيه خالد اهلا بك
معنا ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول المساعدات
التي بدات بالدخول اليوم الى الدخل السوري
نعم طبعا ليس هناك اي جديد بخصوص
المساعدات او المناشدات لدخول المساعدات
كما ذكرنا سابقا بان المساعدات دخلت صباح
اليوم
وعددها اربعه سيارات لكن لم يكن المقصود
بها مساعدات للزلزال الذي ضرب شمال سوريا
بل هي ضمن برنامج الامم المتحده سابقا كان
مقرر ان تدخل في اوقات سابقه
المساعدات خالد يعني حتى ولو كانت مقرره
سابقه ولكنها اقله يعني دخلت الى اين
توزعت في اي مناطق هل توزعت في المناطق
التي ضربها الزلزال ما هي هذه المساعدات
هل هي مواد طبيه مواد غذائيه
نعم المساعدات التي دخلت هي عباره عن مواد
غذائيه وكذلك مواد تنظيف يعني لا دخل لها
باي من الكوارث التي حصلت في الفتره
الاخيره خلال اربعه ايام الان سمعت خبر من
اداره معبر باب السلام بانهم من المتوقع
غدا ان تدخل في المساعدات تكون مخصصه
لهذه الحاله وهي عباره عن بعض الخيام
وكذلك بعض من المعدات الخفيفه للانقاذ
يعني معدات خفيفه ليست من متطلبات الدفاع
المدني وكذلك بعض الاسفنج والحرامات
لانقاذ الناجين والذين خرجوا من تحت
الانقاذ طبعا هذه هي انباء وليست معلومات
مؤكده ربما يتم التنسيق لها غدا صباحا ان
تم الدخول سنعلمكم بشكل مباشر لكن
المساعدات التي طلبت من قبل الدفاع المدني
ومن قبل الفرق لم تدخل حتى هذه اللحظه وما
يزيد الامر صعوبه وقريصه طبعا عن
المساعدات وماذا دخل وماذا سيدخل كنا
سابقا قبل عشر سنوات الشعب السوري كان
يناشد المجتمع الدولي وكذلك الدول المانحه
بضروره تقديم مساعدات لكي ينتهي من هذه
الحرب ينتمي هذا النظام لكن دائما ما كانت
المساعدات تاتي على غير المتوقع والمامول
واليوم ايضا هناك كارثه وزلزال ويطلب
مساعدات المعدات الطبيه لكن ايضا ما يصل
هو غير المامول لا احد يعلم ما هو سبب
تجاهل المجتمع الدولي وما الفرق المتخصصه
التي دخلت وخاصه من الفرق الاسبانيه الى
اين اتجهت الى اي مناطق اتجهت هل الى ريف
حلب هل هي في ريف ادلب هل لدينا معلومات
حولها
هي فرقه واحده فقط والاعداد ليست كبيره
لكن ليس هناك عدد محدد الفرقه الاسبانيه
دخلت الى ريف ادلب
مهمه الفرق الفرقه الاسبانيه هي الكشف عن
الناجين فقط وليست مهمتها الانقاذ او
الانتشال الضحايا هذه الفرقه لديها اجهزه
حديثه لا نملكها نحن في الداخل السوري هي
تستطيع تحديد ما اذا كان داخل المبنى هناك
اشخاص على قيد الحياه ام لا طبعا هذه هي
احد اهم الاسباب التي كان كانت
تؤثر على فقد بعض الاشخاص حياتهم وكذلك
تشغل فرق الدفاع المدني هناك شاهدنا عبر
الانترنت بان هناك يوجد تقنيات حديثه عند
بعض الدول المتقدمه ككاميرات حراريه تكشف
ما اذا كان تحت الانقاض يوجد اشخاص على
قيد الحياه او لا هناك مؤشرات ودرجات
حراره وما شابه لا كل هذه المعدات لا
يملكها الدفاع المدني الذي لا يعني ينقصه
اي جهد لكن تنقصه المعدات كل هذه هي مطالب
من الدفاع المدني يعني ان كانت الدول
الدول الداعمه لا تستطيع او لا تامن على
ارسال اي من فراقها فلتقدم هذه المعدات
تقدم الاليات الثقيله فلتقدم الوسادات
الهوائيه هذا
اليوم ليس هناك اي ناجين لم يتم انتشال
اين جين اليوم في المناطق المنكوبه
اليوم هناك ناجين قبل ساعه او ساعتين
تقريبا تم انتشال ضحايا وبينهم اثنين
ناجين لكن الاعداد باتت يعني في منطقه
جنديرس وكذلك هناك ناجين في مناطق ريف
ادلب بالذكر بان يعني يوم البارحه واليوم
الذي قبله عندما يتم انتشال فلنفرض جدلا
مئه شخص كان هناك من بينهم ناجين ربما يصل
العدد الى 30 او اربعين او ما شابه اليوم
المعلومات الاوليه تم استخراج 100 جثه لكن
عدد الناجين ربما لا يتجاوز 10 اشخاص
السبب الرئيسي في ذلك اين هو يعود بان
اليوم الاول او الثاني ربما كان هناك
اشخاص نجوا من الزلزال لكن لم يموتوا بسبب
النزيف او بسبب البرد او بسبب الجوع وما
شابه لكن اليوم دخلنا انتهينا ربما ننتهي
من اليوم الرابع فكيف سيقوى الانسان على
درجات الطقس البارده جدا الان وكذلك كيف
سي ماء وبدون طعام او احدهم اذا كان لديه
نزيف ولربما صغير كيف سيقوى على مقاومته
هذه المده اي ان بان كل ساعه نتاخر بها عن
هذه تتاخر بها المساعدات عن الداخل السوري
تزيد هناك عدد القتلى كل دقيقه تتاخر فيها
الامم المتحده عن تقديم يد العون للسوريين
يزيد عدد القتلى في هذه المناطق وصراحه
الشعب السوري يرى نفسه مخذولا امام هذه
الكارثه ولا احد اكتارثه او قدم له يد
العون بشكل واقعي وحقيقي ينقذ هذا الشعب
من هذه الماساه
شكرا لك خالد ابو المجد الصحفيه على
الحدود السوريه التركيه على هذه المعلومات
منظمه الدفاع المدني السوريه او ما يعرف
بالخوض البيضاء تقوم بعمليات الانقاذ
واخراج الضحايا من تحت الانقاض في الشمال
السوري وهي الامل الوحيد للمنكوبين بعد
الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه نتابع
في ذروه الخوف والهروب الجماعي في الازمات
والكوارث الطبيعيه منها والتي من صنع
البشر لابد من اثر انساني في الخراب يمد
يد العون وينقذ ما يمكن انقاذه
بعد كارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب الشمال السوري
المقسم اصلا لمناطق تحت سيطره قوى مختلفه
وفي ظل صعوبه وصول المساعدات الطارئه لم
يبقى امل للعالقين تحت الانقاض سوى منظمه
القوه البيضاء والتي لم توقف عملياتها منذ
ايام
الدفاع المدني السوري الذي عرف بخوته
البيض طيله فتره الحرب السوريه على مدار
اكثر من عقد هو القوه الوحيده في الميدان
حاليا تحديدا في مناطق سيطره فصائل
المعارضه في ادلب وشمال حلب نقص الاعانات
والمعدات يعرقل جهود فرقهم ما يؤدي الى
الاعتماد الكلي على الوسائل المتاحه
والبحث اليدوي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مهماتهم بالبحث عن الجثه والناجين بل
تجاوز ذلك الى الاسعاف والبحث عن
المفقودين وذويهم ولم شمل المنكوبين
والتامين الحاجات الاساسيه من غذاء ودواء
وملجا بل والتوفيق ايضا
[تصفيق]
قصص عديده خلال ايام قصيره وثقتها الخوذ
البيض عبر صفحات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ونداءات للمساعده والاعلان عن الناجين
والبحث عن ذويهم
على مر سنوات الحرب السوريه كانت مناطق
النكبات والكوارث والقصف مشاهد الشبه
يوميه يتمسك فيها السكان باقل شعاع امل
للنجاه لتمارس الخوه البيض ذلك الدور ابن
عمر العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من اضنه ينضم الى مراسل العربيه زيدان
اهلا بك معنا اين تتواجد الان اين وصلت
عمليات الانقاذ
نعم نحن في اضنه مدينه اضنه في وسط مدينه
اضنه امام احد المباني المدمره كما
تشاهدين تقريبا عمليات الحفر او عمليه
ازاله الركام والبحث عن جيم تشارف على
نهايتها على نهايتها نحن في الساعات
الاخيره للعمل هنا في هذا الموقع
اليوم الماضي دخلنا على اعتبار اننا دخلنا
الان في يوم جديد يوم الخميس فجر الخميس
استطاعت فرق الانقاذ الخروج او اخراج احد
الاشخاص الذي كان على قيد الحياه طبعا
مساء هذا اليوم وصلت او بدات الجيش التركي
استلم عمليات البحث والانقاذ هنا كدعم
اضافي لفرق المتطوعين قسم كبير من فريق
فرق المتطوعين وفرق الانقاذ انتقلت الى
مواقع اخرى اي ان
العمل تزداد بشكل كبير خلال الساعات
الاخيره والساعات القادمه في اخر
المحاولات واخر الاعمال للوصول الى ناجين
جدد طبعا يعني بعد انتهاء اليوم الرابع
تقريبا نحن شرفنا انتهاء اليوم الرابع من
الكارثه ومقبين على اليوم الخامس نظريا
فرص
العثور على الناجين تتضاءل لكن الانباء
التي تاتي بين الفينه والاخرى بالعثور على
ناجين سواء هنا من هذا الموقع الذي خرج
فيه كما ذكرت قبل قليل
استطاعوا اخراج احد الناجين من هذا الموقع
او حتى
في كهرمان مرعش استطاعوا اخراج طفله بعد
حوالي 92 ساعه تحت الانقاض وايضا على ما
اعتقد ايضا في غاز في كهرمان مرعش استطاع
ايضا اخراج شخص اخر على قيد الحياه هذه
الانباء تعطي دفع معنوي لكل عمال الانقاذ
او كل فرق الانقاذ المتواجدين سواء كان وا
هنا او في ولايات اخرى اي
اي
نعم لا شك ان الاهالي ينتظرون لكن هم
دائما يعني عند وجود الاهالي يكون
الشرطه يعني تحت حمايه ورقابه الشرطه
التركيه يعني احيانا اندفاع الاهالي ربما
يعرقل العمل في هذا في هذه المواقع يعني
على سبيل المثال وهذا اليوم شيء شاهدناه
مساء هذا اليوم كنا على الهواء على ما
اذكر احد الاهالي قرا منشورا عبر وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي يفيد بوجود ثلاثه اشخاص
عالقين تحت
الركام طبعا
بحسب ما اشيع حين هنا في الموقع وبين رجال
الانقاذ ان الشخص الناجي او الشخص الذي
كان على قيد الحياه استطاع استخدام هاتفه
الجوال وكتب في احد حساباته عبر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
انه هو اثنين اخرين على قيد الحياه فهذا
الخبر دفع الكثير من الاهالي الى اختراق
الموقع رغم خطوره الوضع الذي يوجع يعني
الوضع هنا يعني اما عمليات الانقاذ او حتى
الابنيه المتصدعه الاله للسقوط هذا
الموضوع اربك الفرق الانقاذ واضطر الشرطه
الى جلب تعزيزات اخرى واخراج الجميع من
هذا الموقع حتى تستكمل عمليات الانقاذ
يعني طبعا لا شك ان الاهالي معذورون يعني
او معذورين بمثل هذه التصرفات يريدون اي
خبر عن هذا عن ذويهم احبائهم واقربائهم
لكن الشرطه تتخذ اجراءات تحاول ان تبقيهم
نوعا ما بعيدين قدر الامكان عن هذا الموقع
ومواقع اخرى طبعا نتحدث في اضنه اضنه لا
توجد مساحات كبيره متجاوره يعني وهذا شيء
ايجابي والحمد لله مهدمه كما في هاتاي وفي
مرعش او في اديمن لذلك موضوع ضبط الامن في
محيط المواقع التي يتم تتم فيها عمليات
ازاله الركام اسهل من بقيه المناطق الاخرى
التي تشهد دمار واسع وبالتالي ضبط الامور
هناك اصعب بكثير
هل ما زالت مقطوعه لانه في بعض الاحيان
يقولون بانهم قطعوا الكهرباء حتى
خوفا من هزات ارتداديه ان تؤذي ولكن
بالنسبه لاضنا هل الكهرباء مقطوعه جراء
الزلزال ام الحكومه هي من قطعت الكهرباء
تخوفا من اي هزات
الكهرباء
لا توجد مشكله في اضنه في موضوع الكهرباء
يعني كان هناك انقطاعات بعض الزلزال لكن
الاعطال التي حدث تم اصلاحها بسرعه ولا
توجد مشكله ولكن طبعا في المواقع التي تم
العمل فيها هنا يتم استخدامه وليدات ضخمه
الامنيه المجاوره يعني هي بالاساس ابنيه
متصدعه وتم اخلاؤها بالكامل من سكانها منذ
يوم الزلزال ولا يسمح لهم بالعوده لذلك
يتم لا يوجد كهرباء في هذه الابنيه بطبيعه
الحال
لذلك يتم استخدام محاولات كبيره لمواقع
العمل حتى يتم توفير الاضاءه اللازمه
لعمال الانقاذ طيب بالنسبه للبيوت الاخرى
التي لم
تتهدم في الزلزال هل هي مثلا امنه للسكن
فيها ام من او منع مثلا من البقاء في هذه
المنازل القريبه من الابنيه المهدمه
نعم انا اليوم صباحا جلت في مدينه اضنه
حقيقه يعني هناك
صحيح اننا لا يوجد فيها دمار كهاتاي او
كهرمان مرعش او اديمان او غازي عنتاب لكن
حقيقه يعني صدمنا من عدد المباني الاله
للسقوط او المتصدعه خصوصا الابنيه
الطابقيه العاليه هذا يعني لا شك ان كل
هذه الامنيه كلها استثناء هناك
حواجز من الشرطه تمنع دخول اي شخص اليها
وطبعا تم افراغها منذ اللحظات الاولى وتم
اجلاء سكانها الى مخيمات واماكن ايواء
مؤقته منهم طبعا من غادر اضنه الى مناطق
اخرى لكن من بقي في اضنه
اجلائهم الى اماكن ايواء مؤقته ممنوع منعا
باتا تحت اي ظرف كان العوده الى هذه
المنازل قبل التحقق من سلامتها وامكانيه
استخدام المنازل للسكن مره اخرى او او هل
او او امكانيه اجراء تعديلات او ربما في
حال كان الموضوع التصدعات كبيره فهذا يعني
ان البناء سيهدم وبالتالي سيقام مكانه او
ينشا مكانه بناء جديد
على كل حال سنعود اليك في نشره لاحقه
زيدان لنتابع معك عمليه الانقاذ التي ما
زالت مستمره في هذا في هذه البنايه في هذا
المبنى لنعود ونذكر بان هذا المبنى وكان
يتالف من اربعه عشر طابقا
وبالامس كان الحديث بانه رقم التقريبي
للناس المتوقع ان يكونوا متواجدين فيه كان
سنعود اليك فور اي جديد من قبل
عمال هل هذه العمليه من عمليه الانقاذ
شكرا لك
من سرمدا الان ينضم الى حمزه اليوسف
المطوع في الدفاع المدني حمزه اهلا بك
معنا
سندخل اليوم الخامس بعد ساعات لهذا
الزلزال كيف يمكن ان نصف هذا اليوم اين
وصلت عمليات الانقاذ وماذا عن المساعدات
تحياتي لكم جميعا
بدايه الرحمه لجميع الشهداء الزلزال في
سوريا وفي تركيا وفي يعني جميع الضحايا في
كل البلدان الضحايا الزلازل طبعا يعني
الوضع حتى الان الوضع كارثي في معظم
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال هناك لا تزال
الكثير من العوائل تحت انقاض المنازل
المدمره بسبب الزلزال الكبير الذي ضرب
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا هناك يعني دمار كبير
وعائلات لا تزال تحت الانقاض في مدينه
جنديرس في ريف حلب الشمالي بالاضافه الى
عوائل ايضا لا تزال تحت الانقاض في في
مدينه سلقين ومدينه حارم وبلده عزمارين
وايضا قضيه بثانيه وايضا في قريه ملس في
ريف ادلب الغربي يعني حقيقه الوضع كارثي
بشكل كبير
عمليات البحث عن
الناجين تحت الانقاض مستمره حتى هذه
اللحظات كما تحدثتم يعني دخلنا في اليوم
الخامس للكارثه
فاصبحت الامان تتضاءل حمزه يعني اليوم
منير يعني كان معنا قبل
ساعات وقال للاسف يعني اليوم لا انتشال
لاي
لاي جين في الشمال السوري الى اي حد هل في
اي مناطق اخرى اليوم مثلا تم انتشال فيها
اشخاص ما زالوا احياء
[موسيقى]
يعني لم نشاهد هناك اي اي مساعده ايضا قيل
بانه هي دخلت وهي مهمتها العثور على ناجين
هل يمكن ان تعطينا تفاصيل اكثر عن مهمه
هذه الفرقه
تماما يا هناك هناك الفرقه الاسبانيه
تحدثت عنها ايضا يعني تضم خبراء في عمليات
البحث
عمليات الوصول الى المصابين في تحت انقاض
الدمار في ايضا يعني هناك في في معظم
المناطق التي فيها دمار تعمل بالاضافه الى
فرق الدفاع المدني السوري تعمل في منظمات
انسانيه تعمل
فرق تطوعيه من الاهالي في المناطق التي لم
تشهد اضرار كبيره في مناطق ايضا لم تشهد
اي اضرار جراء الزلزال تشكلت فرق تطوعيه
وصلت الى اماكن المتضرره تساعد فرق الدفاع
المدني في عمليات البحث والانقاذ وايضا
اسعاف المصابين تسخير
المعدات المتطوره
بس لو تكرري السؤال يعني كنت اقول بانه
العدد كان كافيا لديكم مثلا لعمليات
الانقاذ كعدد بشري ولكن ما كان ينقصكم
المعدات المتطوره وتقنيات المتطوره التي
تساعد في عمليات الانقاذ وخاصه الالات
الاستشعار التي تعرف اذا كان هناك من نجيء
ام لا
النقص الكبير كان في
لنقول اولا في ماده الديزل لتحريك الاليات
وزياده سرعه زياده عفوا ساعات عملها لتسرب
العمليات الانقاذ هناك ايضا حاجه
لمستشعرات الادوات التقنيه التي تزيد من
يعني ايضا من سرعه الوصول الى المصابين
تحت الانقاض والتواصل معهم وتوجيه يعني
توجيه خلينا نقول الاكسجين الى داخل
الاماكن يعني عندما نعرف ان مثلا هناك شخص
تحت الانقاض في هذا المكان يتم توجيها
الاكسجين اليه بشكل اسرع يتم التواصل معه
لتخفيف الحاله النفسيه التي يمر بها من
الخوف يعني هناك هناك نقص كبير في
معدات
الحديثه تتوفر البعض منها ولكن ليست كافيه
لتغطي جميع المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
خمسه ايام هل
هذه المعدات ان وصلت يعني هل ستساعد باي
شيء ام لا حاجه لها بعد
يعني حقيقه
الجواب على هذا السؤال يعني
يشعرنا بخيبه يشعرنا بالاحباط يعني الطلب
كان منذ الساعات الاولى نداء الانساني كان
من الساعات الاولى لماذا لم نشهد وصول هذه
المساعدات الى مناطق شمال غرب سوريا لماذا
لم تصل هذه المعدات نحن نعمل في سواعد
بسواعد المتطوعين نعمل بسواعد المدنيين
الذين تطوعوا نعمل بكل الطاقات الموجوده
يعني
فرقنا مستعده والمدنيه مستعدون باستمرار
عمليات البحث حتى اخر ساعه حتى اخر يعني
حجر ممكن ان يكون تحتها من خلال خبرتكم من
خلال خبرتكم طبعا في عمليات الانقاذ برايك
الى متى ستستمر عمليات الانقاذ
هل المقصود عمليات عمليات انقاذ لايجاد
ناجين
عمليات عمليات البحث عن ناجين مستمره يمكن
ان تستمر الاسبوع او او عشره ايام تقريبا
يعني لان الدمار كبير يعني مدينه جنديرس
في ريف حلب الشمالي يعني شهدت دمار كبير
جدا في في معظم المنطقه مدينه الصدقين
يعني الى الان نسبه العمل فيها يعني
تصل الى فوق النصف بقليل من امل بعد عشره
ايام او او اكثر ان تجد ناجين حمزه
بالله ان نكونوا
الانقاذ على قيد الحياه ولكن لا يعني نحن
نعمل ضمن يعني مخيلتنا ان هناك انفاس تحت
كل حجر تنتظر من يبعث لها الحياه من جديد
من يساعدها على يعني الخروج من تحت هذه
الالقاب نحن حمزه الان يعني
من المسؤول في هذه المنطقه مع من يتم
التنسيق يعني من المسؤول طبعا انتم تحدثتم
بان هناك خذلان من المجتمع الدولي
والمنظمات الدوليه ولكن بالنسبه للداخل
السوري من هي الجهه المسؤوله الاداره
المسؤوله التي كان يجب ان تسرع ان تنسق ان
تطالب اكثر
هناك يعني منظمات انسانيه هناك الحكومات
موجوده في في شمال غرب سوريا الجميع يعني
تستطيع ان تسرع ايصال المساعدات لكم خاصه
الحكومه الموجوده هناك
اين هي المساعدات بالاساس يعني حتى حتى
اعلانا عن ارسال مساعدات لم يعني لم نشهد
اي اعلانا ارسال المساعدات انسانيه حتى
نقول انه هناك جهه مثلا اخرت او سرعت بهذه
العمليه لم يتم الاعلان عن ارسال مساعدات
الى مناطق شمال غرب سوريا للاسف اقصد انه
هذه الحكومه هناك المسؤوله عن هذه المنطقه
هل قامت بالجهود المطلوبه
لايصال مساعدات الى شمال السوري
سيدتي الكريمه اؤكد لك مره اخرى ايضا يعني
منذ الساعه الاولى تم توجيه نداء انساني
من منظمه تعمل على انقاذ المدنيين هذا
النداء وصل الى كل دول العالم وصل الى
جميع المنظمات الانسانيه الدوليه يعني هذا
النداء يكفي صار نداء يكفي حتى يعني ما
نشر على الصفحات السوشيال ميديا بغض النظر
ان كان هناك طلب من حكومه الحكومات
الغربيه مثلا انه كانت تقول الامور معقده
اكثر من ذلك لانه ليس هناك من نجاح معينه
ينسقون معها هناك عده جهات
الان يعني هل افهم من حديثك انه الدول
يعني
التي كانت سترسل دعم هل هي مثلا توقفت
عندما سوف تنسق معه منظمه الدفاع المدني
السوري هي تعمل على الارض وتنسخ للجهود
يعني المجتمع الدولي المجتمع الدولي من
المفترض ان يكون هناك تنسيق مع المنظمات
العامله على الارض لايصال هذه المساعدات
التقنيه لايصال المواد التي يحتاج تحتاجها
هذه الفرق
لاستمرار عمليات البحث
طبعا نحن نتمنى دائما ان يبقى الامل
موجودا
لايجاد ناجين ما تقومون به ايضا عمل عظيم
يعني كل هذه الكارثه كانت
بجهودكم انتم استطعتم انقاذ اكثر اذا
اردنا ان نتحدث عن من الاعداد التي
انقذتوها حمزه
تعدت 3000 شخص
طبعا حتى هذه اللحظه يعني عدد الوفيات
تجاوز الالفين وفاه تحت الانقاذ بحدود 230
شخص بالاضافه لعمليات عفوا الذين تم
انتشالهم على قيد الحياه واصابتهم يعني
تختلف قدورتها في هناك اصابات خارجيه هناك
اصابات متوسطه العدد
العدد يعني تعتب تخطى عتبه عفوا تخطى عتبه
تم انتشالهم على قيد الحياه ولكن كما ذكرت
هناك يعني الكثير منهم عصابات حرجه الكثير
منهم من النساء والاطفال نتمنى لهم طبعا
الشفاء العاجل وطبعا الرحمه لان الذين
قضوا خلال هذا
الزلزال اشكرك حمزه اليوسف المطوع في
الدفاع المدني من سرمدا طبعا يعني الدفاع
المدني قام بواجبه على اكمل وجه وكان هو
يعني كما يقال الامل الوحيد بالنسبه
للسكان المنكوبين شكرا لك
الان من ادلب عبر سكايبي ينضم اليه
الصحفيه مسلم السيد عيسى مسلم اهلا بك
معنا اليوم كيف يبدو المشهد اليوم بالامس
تحدثنا معك
وايضا ايضا اعطيتنا يعني صوره عن الكارثه
وعن ابرز
التطورات التي حصلت على الارض بالنسبه
لليوم ماذا لدينا
نعم مساء الخير حقيقه يعني الوضع مشابه
لما حدث خلال الثلاث ايام الاولى انتهى
اليوم الرابع
الماساه تتكشف شيء فشيء واعداد المفقودين
تتكشف ايضا ربما يعني ايجاد جثتهم تحت
الانقاض وربما ايضا بفقد الامل من الوصول
اليهم ما حصل حتى هذه اللحظه هو انتشار
يعني تقريبا حوالي 20 شخص على قيد الحياه
خلال اخر 24 ساعه او ربما اكثر يعني ليسوا
ليس ليس فقط استاذ منير من الدفاع المدني
كان معي قبل ساعتين وقال للاسف انه اليوم
لم يتم انتشال اي ناجي
نعم اخر ما تم انتشاله هو في مدينه جنديرس
قبل اكثر من 24 ساعه كانت ثلاث ثلاث اشخاص
طفل ورجل وامراه بعدها لم يتم انتشار اي
من الاشخاص على قيد الحياه وايضا حتى ما
تم انتشالهم اعداد قليله مقارنه بالايام
الاولى
بينما تزداد اعداد المغيبين والمفقودين
الاهالي تبلغ يوميا وكل ساعه عن عشرات
المفقودين الذين لا يزالون تحت الانقاض
وربما ايضا
الاهالي نتيجه انقطاع هنا كل الخدمات
الانترنت والتواصل وغيرها لا تعرف من نجا
ومن خرج ومن هو مصاب وايضا من هو تحت
الانقاذ فرقه الدفاع المدني كما ذكرتم قبل
قليل تحاول لكن على الشق الانساني وهذا ما
يعني انا اليوم كنت ابحث في الكثير من
المناطق واتنقل في مناطق المنكوبه بشكل
مباشر الوضع الانساني حقيقه دائره
الاحتياجات تتوسع بشكل مخيف
فينا مسلم يعني ما هي ابرز الاحتياجات
التي الناس الان هي بحاجه اليها من خلال
مشاهداتك
وطبعا مراقبتك على الارض
نعم انا يعني جل تقريبا كل المناطق
المنكوبه في شمال غرب محافظه ادلب اليوم
اغلب الاحتياجات كانت بشكل اساسي وهو ما
يعني ربما يفاجئ المشاهدين هي مواد
التدفئه خرجت كلها هذه العوائل الاف
العوائل الى العراء بملابس المنزل كل
الاطفال والنساء والرجال كانوا يلبسون
يعني اشياء بسيطه ربما هي تصلح لداخل
المنزل والان هم في العراء درجات الحراره
تقترب من الصفر هنا في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي هم اكثر ما يحتاجونه الان ان
اتحدث عن الناجين مواد التدفئه من مدافئ
ومواد للدفء كانت الاطفال ما شاهدته بعيني
تماما يجمعون النايلون والبلاستيك
والاخشاب وغيرها ليضعوها حيثما جلسوا
ويتدفعوا عليها على الشق الاخر ايضا هناك
حاجه ماسه للتغذيه والغذاء المطبوخ الجاهز
هذه العوائل ايضا لا تملك اي امكانيات هي
خرجت بدون اي شيء معها وبالتالي تحتاج من
يقدم لها الطعام لتاكله مباشره هنا
المنظمات المحليه تساهم بتقديم هذه
الاشياء لكن ضمن حدود متوسطه حتى هذه
اللحظه
والجدير بالذكر اليوم ما شاهدته هو بدء
الحملات الشعبيه
يعني المساجد كانت تنادي مكبرات الصوت
للاهالي في المناطق التي كانت وتيره
الكارثه فيها اقل لان تقدم الاهالي كل ما
لديها من ملابس وغيرها هذه الحاله ربما
تسد فجوه صغيره على ارض الواقع من الماساه
انا ذكرت في البدايه ان دائره الاحتياجات
تتوسع بشكل مخيف اولا نتيجه يعني افراغ
مستودعات المؤسسات الانسانيه في كارثه
الشتاء قبل يوم واحد فقط من كارثه الزلزال
وبالتالي ليس هناك اي امكانيات محليه
التعويل في هذه الايام بالضبط وبشكل مباشر
على المساعدات
التي تاتي من الخارج المعلومات عن المعابر
مسلم هل من مؤشرات لاي مساعدات ستدخل من
هذه المعابر التي تصل الى الداخل السوري
نعم اود التاكيد هنا على نقطه جدا مهمه
الان قبل دقائق تواصلت مع المدير
العلاقاتي معبر باب الهوى اكد ان هناك
قاتله ستدخل غدا من المتوقع قبل الظهر وهي
قافله من المساعدات مساعدات الحكومه
السعوديه هي 12 شاحنه محمله بالمواد
الاغاثيه هي جاهزه في الطرف التركي وتم
تعبئتها وتجهيزها وستدخل غدا ربما قبل ظهر
الغد عبر معبر باب الهوى والى الداخل
السوري وهي اول قافله فعليا ستصل الى هذه
المنطقه كما ذكرت هي من المساعده مساعدات
الحكومه السعوديه تم تجهيزها بالقرب من
معبر باب الهوى من الجانب التركي في قرب
مستودعات منظمه وستدخل غدا الى الحدود عبر
الحدود السوريه التركيه الى مناطق ادلب
لتوزع مباشره
على كل حال مسلم دائما نحن نشكرك على
المشاركه معنا وتعطينا هذه الصوره عما
يحصل في مختلف المناطق في ريف ادلب وايضا
الوضع الانساني هناك اشكرك من ادلب عبر
سكايب الصحفيه مسلم السيد عيسى
اعلن المدير العالم منظمه الصحه العالميه
تدرس ادانوب انه في طريقه الى سوريا مؤكدا
دعم منظمه الصحه العالميه بالمساعدات
الطبيه للمناطق التي تاثرت بالزلزال
وكانهم اعلن تخصيص ثلاثه ملايين دولار من
صندوق الطوارئ لدعم عمليات الاستجابه
للمتضررين من الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا
فضلا عن ارسال فرق من الخبراء وطائرات
محمله بامدادات طبيه
اما المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكان
برايس فقال ان المساعدات الامريكيه الى
سوريا لن تذهب الى النظام
هذه المساعدات لن تذهب الى النظام ولكن
ستذهب الى الشركاءنا الدوليين على الارض
وبعضهم موجود هناك منذ 12 عاما سيستخدمون
هذه المساعدات ليضمنوا انها ستكون فعاله
لا نفرض عقوبات على المساعدات الانسانيه
وعاده ما نعمل على ضمان وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه للمحتاجين ولهذا المساعده
الانسانيه تصل الى الشركاء على الارض وحتى
في المناطق التي يسيطر عليها النظام
معارك الانقاذ الدائره في المناطق
المنكوبه في سوريا وتركيا تقابلها معارك
صمود تحت الحطامى الا ان بعضها بات في حكم
الخاسر في السباق مع الوقت توافق خبراء
كوارث تقل الامال بانتشال احياء بعد مرور
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه من وقوع الزلزال
اثنتان 72 ساعه توصف بالذهبيه انتهت
والنافذه الاكثر احتمالا لانقاذ ارواح
شارفت على الاغلاق وفق معظم خبراء الكوارث
فالوقت ليس لصالحهم بل يضعف الامال بسحب
العالقين من تحت الانقاض احياء
عند خالك تعي
ير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر لا اله الا الله اصوات خرجت من
تحت الركام في الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
بعضها لحقتها يد المساعده واخرى صمتت
تدريجيا بعد ان اتعبها ثقل الحطام وقسوه
البرد فخسرت المعركه نحن نسمع صوت من تحت
الالقاب نسعى جاهدين باتجاه النصل الى هذا
الصوت ولكن حقيقه البارحه يعني الوضع كان
كارثي عند مصل الى هذا الشخص نجده قد فارق
الحياه عوامل اللوجستيه عده عرقلت عمليه
الانقاذ ضعف الموارد ونقص المعدات
والاليات المخصصه للرفع ادى لاوقات
استجابه بطيئه وساهم بزياده عدد الضحايا
لينقل ناشطون اقدام اشخاص على حفر التراب
باظافرهم لعلهم يعثرون على ناجين
قاتل ابن عمنا لمده 30 ساعه كنا نستطيع
رؤيته ويمكننا التحدث اليه لكن لم ياتي
احد من الحكومه
العواصف الثلجيه تضاعفت الكارثه مع ملامسه
درجات الحراره الصفر مع عرقل عمليات تتحدى
نقص الامكانات اصلا
نادت من اول لحظه بانها بان الكارثه اكبر
من القدرات الموجوده عند الفوز البيضاء في
الحقيقه نقص المعدات يعني ادى الى للاسف
الى فقدان الكثير من العالقين وفقدان
ارواحهم قصص نهار لا يمحوها ليل بل يزيد
فصولها قسوه وتعذيبا اشخاص تمسكوا لثلاثه
ايام بسماع اصوات شاكيه وباكيه هرعوا
خلفها ثم حضروا لحظات اختفائها تدريجيا
عجز ضاعف وقع المصيبه
رغم حاله الحرب التي تعيشها اوكرانيا
وحاجتها الكبيره الى فرق الاغاثه الا ان
كياف بادلت الى ارسال فريق من رجال
الانقاذ الى تركيا للمساعده في انتشال
ضحايا زلزال
[موسيقى]
معلمنا
هذه الساعه الاخباريه لمتابعه تداعيات هذا
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا انتهت ولكن تغطيه العربيه ما زالت
مستمره اما الان ستكون مع الزميل طاهر
بركي اليك طاهر